rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir un sentier très facile et
accessible à tous le sentier botanique
de la petite plaine entre la plaine des
palmistes et bébour j'ai besoin de la
lui
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
passage obligé pour rejoindre bébour la
petite plaine n'est pas forcément une
zone très connue des randonneurs à
quelques mètres de la route juste à côté
des kiosques à pique nique il existe
pourtant un sentier botanique faciles à
découvrir du soleil pour me chauffer la
vie j'ai besoin de la mer le départ du
sentier matérialisée par un panneau là
même où la forêt de cryptomerias but sur
la forêt primaire
rares sont les occasions de voir une
transition aussi nette comme un passage
dans un autre monde
tout à côté de moi j'ai tant besoin de
tous dès les premiers pas l'immersion
dans la forêt primaire est totale et les
espèces emblématiques facilement
observables pas bah tiens la hache pour
être montré un arbre assez sympa comme
on a un juvénile et un adulte un
hibiscus moriani ça on le reconnaît à
comme les feuilles d'hibiscus qu'on a
dans nos jardins mais bon celui là il
pousse en forêt il est endémique et à
côté là nous avons justement un tout
petit alors la particularité c'est qu'il
a des feuilles et théophile c'est à dire
les feuilles de bis q jeunes sont
différentes des feuilles adultes vous
voyez là c'est complètement différent du
de l'hibiscus qu'on voit
bien adultes les feuilles sont
différentes celui là aussi fait des
fleurs un petit peu jaune orangé
malheureusement ce n'est pas la saison
des fleurs mais si vous venez ici en été
vous pouvez marcher sur les petites
fleurs d'hibiscus d'état dire on les
reconnaît facilement il ressemble un
petit peu bas pratiquement ce qu'on a
dans nos jardins mais on avec une petite
différence sont plus petits
très vite le sentier tourner sur la
gauche mais sur la droite une rapide
descente permet de rejoindre le bras
noirs et sa petite cascade
sur la falaise les traces permet de se
rendre compte jusqu'à quelle hauteur la
ravit le second fait en période de pluie
impressionnant
de retour sur le sentier ne vous
attendez pas à plus d'explications peu
entretenues les panneaux explicatifs
sont quasi inexistants il faudra être
particulièrement observateurs mais ne
vous méprenez pas les espèces les plus
facilement repérables sont parfois des
exotiques comme cd gogniat qui font
partie des espèces envahissantes
maintien d'une variété de bégonias l' ac
bégonias qu'on retrouve souvent dans nos
jardins conquis six plaies mal acquis
cip est très bien en forêt et qui a
tendance à envahir le sous bois au
dessus c'est la plainte des caps donc il
suffit qu'un ruissellement emmène
quelques plantes et comme il se
développe très bien puisque ça ou que ce
cas c'est ça vous mettez pas refaire ça
repart facilement les espèces
envahissantes ont une très forte sont
très compétitives par rapport aux
espèces locales viennent souvent des
continents ouhlala la concurrence était
déjà bien établies alors qu'ici avait
pas de concurrence avec enfin les
espèces ne faut rentrer pas forcément en
compétition entre elles alors que ces
espèces exotiques ont un fort pouvoir de
développement d'installations sur les
terrains dès qu'il ya un éboulis une
friche ici ici ici un sale très très
vite alors quelles espèces locales mais
beaucoup plus de temps quand même à
s'installer
c'est la loi du plus fort c'est la loi
malheureusement de l'exotisme sur
l'endémisme l'indigène
même sans panneaux explicatifs il est
aisé de reconnaître des espèces aussi
emblématique que le bois de savon
le franchissement d'une petite ravine a
été facilitée par l'aménagement d'une
passerelle
pas de doute cette randonnée sans
dénivelé ni difficulté majeure est
accessible à tout public
c'est déjà le chemin du retour et les
cryptomérias forment à nouveau une
limite net même si les arbres de la
forêt primaire sont ici particulièrement
aux
alors là on attaque le chemin du retour
et on est en lisière de forêt on va dire
forêt primaire 1 et en lisière de
cryptomérias donc forêts cultivées ici
la transition est beaucoup moins
flagrante elle c'est vrai qu'on retrouve
les arbres à peu près un petit peu à peu
près à la même hauteur des cryptomérias
contrairement aux différents paysages
comme au niveau du piton de l'eau ou
c'est flagrant il ya là une différence
de hauteur flagrante alors qu'ici bas
tout ce ce phénomène pied de falaise
profite aux arbres de l'effet d'érosion
de la falaise qui ramène beaucoup plus
de terres donc beaucoup plus propice aux
arbres à se développer à avoir une bonne
hauteur quand même nom on a vraiment les
arbres la forêt primaire qui côtoie
facilement au niveau auteurs les
cryptomérias replanter
sur le chemin du retour d'autres espèces
comme ceux ficus s'offre à notre regard
et notre touchés
après avoir dépassé une vieille
forestière c'est le retour au début de
la boucle qui matérialise la fin de
notre randonnée
tout y est un
mois je voulais montrer un petit sentier
facile qui est ouvert à toute la famille
comme vous voyez sur ce sentier n'y a
pas de difficultés tout le monde peut
aussi embarquer c'est pas très long on
est à l'abri du soleil d'ailleurs
j'invite les réunionnais de 7 à 77 ans
emboîtera venir faire une petite
découverte que ce soit une petite balade
digestive ou justement une petite balade
pour croiser l'appétit quand vous venez
pique-niqué pour la petite reine pas
besoin d'être randonneurs j'aille sur le
plat book elle pas très longue pas
besoin d'avoir de matériels spécifiques
type 2 ou si vous voulez mais vraiment
ou faire vraiment antique tout public
c'est un petit peu un voyage à travers
le temps parce que depuis même avant
l'arrivée de l'homme c'est forêt était
là et même avec la présence de l'homme
cette forêt est toujours là on voyage à
fréland le temps et surtout bas comme je
dirais enfin ce contraste juste à côté
c'est la vie tous les jours et là une
immersion un petit peu aussi bas dans de
notre patrimoine ce que j'aime pas sur
cette rando c'est vrai que quand on dit
ouverte à tous le monde parfois on est
dans l'est s'il pleut elle peut être un
petit peu glissant faut faire un petit
peu attention mais c'est pas y'a pas de
danger spécifique on peut s'aventurer
c'est juste petit côté ça peut être
glissant s'il a plus la vague